في تفاصيل المشهد الميداني الان في غزه
خلال الساعه الماضيه افاد مراسلنا
بالتواصل القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي في
محيط مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس جنوبي قطاع
غزه وقد دفع القصف اعدادا كبيره من سكان
المناطق المجاوره للمستشفى للنزوح من
منازلهم الى مناطق اكثر امنا كما اطر
النازحون في المستشفى للخروج منه مع تواصل
القصف الاسرائيلي والاشتباكات قرب المص
مستشف الى مستشفى ناصر الان مع مؤمن شرافي
مراس الجزيره مؤمن ايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك
قنابل مضيئه في اجواء المستشفى ما هو
طبيعه الوضع
الميداني نعم محمد طبيعه الاوضاع
الميدانيه في محيط مستشفى ناصر وفي في
المناطق القريبه منه من الناحيه الجنوبيه
ومن الجهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه للمستشفى هي
امور تزداد سخونه مع استمرار اي القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي وايضا سماع دوي
اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه من قبل الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى ان
الطائرات المسيره الاسرائيليه تطلق نيران
اسلحتها على عدد من المناطق المحيطه
بالمستشفى ايضا قوات احتلال اطلقت عددا من
القنابل الضوئيه في اجواء المستشفى فوق
مستشفى ناصر بالاضافه الى ان هناك حديث من
قبل شهود عيان ان قناصه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يعتلون عددا من الابنيه
السكنيه المرتفعه في منطقه بطن السمين
المطله على المناطق القريبه والمحيط
بالمستشفى ويطلقون نيران اسلحتهم بين
الفين والاخرى
دوي الانفجارات وايضا الاشتباكات المستمره
منذ نحو اربع ساعات لا تتوقف حتى هذه
اللحظه مع تحليق مكثف للطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على ارتفاعات منخفضه
وايضا للطائرات الاستطلاع المصيره
الاسرائيليه اوما يعرف محليا هنا في غزه
بال الزنانه حتى هذه اللحظه وصعوبه
الاوضاع ميدانيا وفي ساعات الليل يصعب
التاكد تماما من اماكن التي توغلت فيها
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه لكن هي تبعد
مئات الامتار او اكثر عن الجهه الجنوبيه
من مستشفى ناصر وتحاول التقدم
باتجاه الغرب او الجهه الشماليه وسط اطلاق
نار كثيف وايضا اطلاق قصف مدفعي عشوائي
يستهدف منازل المواطنين في الحي النمساوي
وايضا محيط المستشفى المدان
مؤم نعم و وشاهدنا ذلك داخل المستشفى ن
الى اين ذهب الناس مؤمن في في هذه الاوقات
وفي هذه الظروف بحثا عن مكان
امن الى لا شيء
محمد في ساعات الليل المتاخر تتحدث في
اجواء بارده اعداد كبيره من سكان المناطق
المحيطه بالمستشفى وايضا اعداد كبيره من
النازحين الذين اووا واحتموا
في داخل اسوار المستشفى من القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه خرجوا من منازلهم وايضا خرجوا
من المستشفى الى
الشوارع العامه المحيطه والبحث عن مناطق
اكثر امنا بعيدا عن القصف
والنيران التي تفتحها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بشكل كثيف كما تسمعون الان وهي
يبدو انها ناجم عن اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه
تدور في تلك المنطقه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي تحاول التصدي لمحاولات
تقدم اسرائيليه في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
مستشفى ناصر الاخطر في الموضوع وان هذا
المستشفى هو المستشفى الرئيسي حاليا في
عموم قطاع غزه بعد اخراج قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مجمع الشفاء الطبي في مدينه
غزه عن الخدمه ان خرج هذا المستشفى عن
الخدمه
بفعل الضربات والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي
الكثيف فانك تضع حياه الالاف من الجرحى ج
استمرار الحرب والاسرائيليه والغارات
الجويه لاسرائيل امام خطر حقيقي في ظل
امكانيات دنيا من المستلزمات الطبيه وايضا
المعدات اللازمه لاجراء العمليات الجراحيه
ونقص حاد في الادويه ونقص اكبر في الكوادر
الطبيه امام الاعداد الكبيره التي ترد
يوميا الى مستشفى ناصر من الجرحى جراء
تواصل الغارات والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي
منذ بدء العمليه البريه على الاقل هنا في
محافظه خانيونس دوي اطلاقات الناريه
الكثيفه من الاليات والدبابات الاسرائيليه
لا يتوقف على مدار الاربع ساعات الماضيه
الى جانب القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي الذي
يسمع دوي انفجارات بشكل كبير في مناطق
قريبه من مستشفى نصر من الجهه الجنوب مؤمن
معكم على مدار الايام الماضيه ربما يعني
هذه الليله غير مسبوقه يعني اصوات القصف
والانفجارات ربما لم نستمع اليها من قبل
بهذه الكثافه هذا يدفع لسؤال عن مناطق
اخرى يعني هل هنالك جديد فيما يتعلق ب
المناطق الاخرى في في خانيونس وما الذي
يجري فيها ما الذي دفع الامور الى هذه
الكثافه في
النيران جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي محمد
يكثف خلال الساعات الاخيره من قصفه وتقدم
من محاولات تقدم الياته في المحور الجنوب
النوبي الشرقي من المدينه وايضا الى
الجنوب من مدينه خانيونس المحور الجنوبي
الشرقي منذ على الاقل خمسه ايام يشهد
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال تحديدا تتحدث
في منطقه قيزان النجار جوت اللوط محيط بطن
السمين محيط كليه العلوم والتكنولوجيا
التي شهدت خلال الايام السابقه اشتباكات
مسلحه عنيفه اسرائيل تستخدم في محاولات
تقدمها تقدمها بريا كثافه ناريه من قبل
المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وقصف مدفعي
كثيف تمهيدا لتقدم الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيلي اتجاه الاهداف التي يسعى جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الوصول اليها لكن حتى
اللحظه من دوي اطلاقات الناريه الكثيفه
نسمع دوي اشتباكات ومحاولات من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للتصدي لمنع تقدم الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اكثر الى الجهه
انطلاقا من الجهه الشرقيه باتجاه الجهه
الغربيه من محافظه خانيونس وسط قصف مدفعي
كما تسمعون لا يتوقف خلال الساعات الاخيره
وفي كل دقيقه نسمع دوي انفجارات ناجمه عن
قصف من الدبابات والعمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه يستهدف المناطق التي تحاول
التوغل بها القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عبر طبعا مدرعات ودبابات محصنه تحاول
المقامه الفلسطينيه استهدافها ب الصواريخ
المضاده للدروع وايضا بالعبوات الناسفه مع
انتشار للقناصه على عدد من الابنيه
المرتفعه في محيط المنطقه التي تتوغل فيها
اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اتمنى لكم السلامه مؤمن الشرافي مراسل
الجزيره من مستشفى ناصر بخانيونس